given the situation after the no vote in
Greece we need to hear from the Greek
government first get boldly it's
abundantly clear that the ball is in the
court of the Greek government is now to
the greek Finance Minister mystics are
gonna do so the old proposals have been
rejected by the great people the main
problem is what are the concrete
proposals which will be on the table we
will await new proposals concrete
proposals give good proposals clear and
credible strategy trainable reforms
unfortunately as I recovery which is so
lost last year has been a waste we need
for the Frank clear a good discussion in
order to to avoid the worst which will
be the dressing it's not our aim it's
not our intention we are working towards
the scenario where we could reach the
agreement Tracy to be a painter would be
a terrible mistake to be a collective
failure we don't want it the Commission
doesn't want it but if Trust is not
revealed if there is no credible reform
package and place it cannot be exploded
with the representatives of the
institution and I definitely don't
accept at all that the Commission and
its president were declared terrorists
by the Greek government side that is not
how one deals in Europe we now need
really to restore trust between 19
eurozone democracies only then we will
be able to move forward there is a great
sense of urgency time is very short and
more so as we
guess as we go off